Traduttore: Maria Pia Lanfranchi
Revisore: Sofia Ramundo
[idee con le ali]
(musica)
[anime e persone con
le radici]
(musica)
(Applausi)
Qualche anno fa ho avuto
un'idea per un documentario
che secondo me era un'idea geniale,
e sono andata a presentarla
ad un canale televisivo.
L'idea era quella di seguire
due ragazzi in Cina,
un ragazzo gay, Andy,
che era alla disperata ricerca
di una ragazza lesbica
per organizzare un matrimonio finto,
per fare felici i suoi genitori;
e l'altra ragazza, invece, Cherry,
che è una ragazza lesbica,
già sposata,
e quindi a questo punto
era alla disperata ricerca di un figlio,
perché i suoi genitori le chiedevano,
chiaramente, di procrearli.
Quando ho finito la mia presentazione,
il direttore del canale mi guarda
e dice: "Carina, molto carina questa idea,
però fammi un attimo capire:
tu vuoi fare un documentario in Cina,
per un canale olandese,
vivi a Londra e sei italiana.
E sei qui e vuoi dei soldi da me."
A quel punto
questa cosa mi fece molto riflettere.
Prima di tutto pensai
che non sarei mai riuscita
a fare il film che avrei voluto
e poi mi fece un po' riflettere
sul mio stile di vita.
Sul mio stile di vita e quello,
comunque, dei miei colleghi.
Io sono una documentarista,
una regista di documentari,
e come i miei colleghi,
nell'arco della mia vita
finirò per collezionare
un certo numero di case.
E per case intendo in senso ampio,
tutto ciò che ci dà
un senso di appartenenza.
Questo in realtà può essere una città,
può essere una nazione,
può essere uno stile di vita.
E finiamo quindi per diventare
una sorta di nomadi moderni:
continuiamo a cambiare case,
molto di frequente.
Ma perché è importante essere nomadi?
Non solo per i documentaristi,
ma in generale.
E com'è che questo poi va
a cambiare la percezione del sé?
Allora, prima di tutto diciamo che:
ognuno di noi nasce, cresce,
ed è all'interno di un circolo,
di un cerchio sociale e culturale.
Nasciamo in una certa famiglia,
in un paese,
facciamo parte
di una certa classe sociale.
Se non usciamo
al di fuori del nostro cerchio,
se rimaniamo all'interno
di ciò che conosciamo,
con delle persone che ci assomigliano,
rischiamo di atrofizzarci,
e l'immaginazione viene a mancare.
Per cui un modo per uscire
dal ghetto culturale
in cui possiamo finire
è quello di...
è usando il mezzo dello story-telling,
cioè la narrazione di storie,
ed è tramite le storie
che riusciamo ad avere
una visione dell'altro,
e a volte quello che vediamo
può anche finire per piacerci.
Come dicevo, io frequento molto
i miei colleghi:
sono persone che vengono
da tutto il mondo,
hanno viaggiato in tutto il mondo,
lavorato, amato, in tanti paesi diversi
rispetto al paese di origine,
e spesso sento dire da queste persone
che si sentono
molto più a loro agio con i loro colleghi
piuttosto che con le persone che vengono
dallo stesso paese o dalla stessa città.
E quindi questa cosa spesso
mi ha fatto riflettere:
se davvero questo vuol dire
che abbiamo perso le nostre radici.
In realtà non credo che sia così.
Piuttosto, più che perdere
le proprie radici,
dobbiamo imparare a vivere
tra mondi diversi,
case diverse, dai posti
che riconosciamo come case.
Io in particolare ho viaggiato molto,
sono nata e cresciuta a Reggio Calabria,
e poi sono andata a vivere a Torino,
dove ho fatto l'università,
ho fatto ancora un anno
di dottorato di ricerca,
poi sono andata a vivere a Londra
dove sono rimasta nove anni.
In questi nove anni, in realtà,
ho passato tanto tempo in Cina,
ad Amsterdam, in Israele,
in tanti altri posti,
perché il lavoro che faccio -
che io amo definire un privilegio
più che un lavoro -
mi porta a viaggiare
e a stare molto tempo nei luoghi
e con le persone,
perché ho bisogno di instaurare
un rapporto di fiducia,
di diventare una specie di amica
di queste persone,
che quindi devono aprirsi
di fronte alla telecamera,
proprio perché il tipo
di documentario che faccio,
che si chiama "di osservazione",
cioè io seguo delle persone
in modo tale che le loro storie
si sviluppino di fronte alla telecamera.
Non utilizzo interviste.
E quindi ho davvero bisogno
di stare molto vicina a queste persone.
Per farvi capire meglio,
vi faccio vedere due clip:
nella prima clip, c'è Cherry,
la ragazza lesbica che non aveva detto
ai suoi genitori di essere gay,
e il mio film si focalizza proprio
sul rapporto
tra genitori e figli,
le difficoltà tra genitori e figli,
per cui volevo, chiaramente,
andare a filmare i suoi genitori
in modo tale da ottenere delle scene
in cui fosse evidente
la difficoltà, le pressioni,
le incomprensioni
e i problemi tra di loro.
E quando glielo dissi,
lei mi disse i rapporti che c'erano
e mi disse "sì, vieni"
e mi invitò a casa dei suoi.
A quel punto nasceva il problema
di cosa dire ai suoi genitori,
e lei ebbe questa idea
di dire ai suoi genitori
e a tutto il paesino sperduto in Cina,
che eravamo lì
per fare un documentario sui gamberetti.
E quindi adesso vedrete il video.
Invece l'altra clip, nell'altra clip
vedrete l'altro protagonista
del documentario,
Andy, ma non ha bisogno
di grandi introduzioni.
Se è possibile mandare i video adesso...
grazie.
(video in cinese)
(video in inglese)
Chiaramente abbiamo mangiato
chili e chili di gamberetti
e abbiamo ore e ore di girato
con i gamberetti
e potremmo fare un intero
documentario sui gamberetti
perché, appunto, siamo dovuti stare
moltissimo tempo a casa di Cherry
per riuscire ad ottenere queste immagini
in modo tale che loro si sono
quasi dimenticati
della presenza della telecamera.
Per quanto riguarda Andy, invece,
non l'ho sposato, nel caso in cui
ve lo steste chiedendo.
Quindi, cosa succede:
una volta finita una storia
bisogna passare alla storia successiva,
quindi la mobilità è vissuta
come una necessità,
è importante muoversi
per acquisire nuove conoscenze.
Conoscere nuovi personaggi,
nuove storie
e interessarsi a temi diversi.
Questo, appunto, come dicevo prima,
ci rende un po' una tribù
di nomadi moderni:
continuiamo a muoverci e, diciamo,
questo fa sì che diventiamo
delle persone che non sono definite,
non abbracciano una zona definita,
un unico luogo, un'unica appartenenza.
Questo stile di vita porta anche
delle cose negative, chiaramente:
in primis, questo continuare a muoversi,
innamorarsi dei luoghi
in cui si va a stare,
fa sì che lasciamo un pezzettino di cuore
in ognuno di questi luoghi;
e l'altro problema è quello che spesso
diventa difficile definire
che cosa è casa,
il concetto di casa.
Però abbiamo tutti bisogno
di avere una casa,
abbiamo bisogno delle radici,
abbiamo bisogno di qualcosa
in cui identificarci,
sia perché questo ci serve, poi,
per mantenere una visione,
una passione,
sia perché ci serve per collegarci,
connetterci con i nostri personaggi,
con il nostro audience,
con il pubblico e con noi stessi.
E alla fine ci rendiamo conto
che avere un'appartenenza
ci libera più di quanto non ci costringa.
E quindi alla fine si giunge
alla conclusione che
più che imparare a vivere
senza una casa
o lontano da casa,
bisogna imparare a vivere tra case.
Tra luoghi.
Il luogo da cui si proviene,
in cui si è nati e cresciuti,
e i luoghi in cui
ci siamo sentiti a casa.
Questo da un punto di vista emozionale
è chiaramente difficile
perché richiede di stare in un posto
per un periodo abbastanza lungo
ma viaggiare anche moltissimo,
richiede passare tempo
con le persone vicine,
ma essere vicino alle persone lontane.
E spesso è molto difficile
riuscire a colmare i vuoti
tra le case.
Però è anche un enorme privilegio
poter abitare in così tante case
ed è un privilegio che il regista
di documentari condivide,
condivide raccontando delle storie,
appunto facendo dei film.
E il fine ultimo è quello di
raccontare delle storie universali
che colmino, che possano colmare
le distanze tra mondi che sono
molto distanti tra di loro.
Alla fine, il direttore del canale
al quale avevo presentato
questa idea all'inizio
si convinse, il film è stato fatto,
è andato molto bene,
è stato venduto in tanti Paesi diversi
e questo, mi piace pensare che, appunto,
sia un mestiere universale,
che tutti possano in qualche modo capire
e immedesimarsi nelle storie
dei personaggi del film.
E quindi, torno al fine ultimo
del documentario
ma poi non solo dei documentari,
ma in generale, raccontare storie,
ascoltare storie è importante
perché quello che facciamo
è uscire dal nostro piccolo mondo
e andare ad esplorare
quello che c'è là fuori,
e andare a conoscere
quello che è diverso da noi.
Grazie.
(applausi)